- I'd like to introduce
you to the filmmaker,
Charly Frisk, who's sitting here,
and who is a student at
the School of Environment,
I guess it's called now,
used to be called the Forestry School.
In any case, and she has
made a number of videos
or films before this.
So she's a filmmaker,
and there you have it.
So, questions to the speaker.
- [Audience] Yeah, so,
I'm Nordwig (indistinct)
in English.
I'm a visiting researcher
at the law school
and I am a (indistinct) and my
PhD was about the regulation
of seed systems in Sub-Saharan Africa.
- Okay.
- Specifically Francophone
Africa, Senegal,
and Burkina Faso.
And I'm from Belgium,
so I know the European
system a little bit.
- Okay.
- I think you're doing a
very good job of explaining
and making palpable both
for me but also for people
who haven't really worked on this perhaps,
making palpable why it's so
important to not only have
conservation in the seed bank,
but also in situ as they say.
- Yeah.
- In fields and to have
this as living knowledge.
There's plenty of comments
going through my mind.
One of it is, I don't know
how this comes across,
but at some point you mentioned
the international union
for protection of new
varieties of plants UPOV,
that's actually legally not correct.
- Oh.
- That one shouldn't have been there.
So I don't know if there's
any editing you can
do anymore because it's an
intellectual property union.
It doesn't have anything
to do with market access
and what plant varieties
are allowed to be cultivated
in the field.
So for, that's the comment.
What I wanted to know is,
but you've already told
a little bit like how did you,
why did you wanna make this movie?
And then how did you film this?
How did you produce this?
Was it just you, was it
with a handheld camera?
And especially what motivated you,
what fascinated you to make this.
- Yeah, thank you for your question.
It's cool that you've also
researched this and everything
and I would love to talk
to you more about that.
That sounds amazing.
Yeah, I've been making films
since I was really young.
I had my parents take home
videos of me since I was three.
And then when I was in
high school, my dad gave me
all the films that they had
taken over my entire childhood
and asked me to organize it.
And once I went through all
those films, then he was like,
okay, now you can edit.
And they both do graphic
designing on the side
and so they had Adobe Premier Pro.
So I learned video editing
at a very young age
and started really just
getting passionate about
the power of film and
how it can just take you
to a different place.
And then in college I was
a part of a student led
documentary team and we focused
on social justice issues
and made a documentary every year.
And the documentary my sophomore year,
we focused on refugees
and receiving communities
as well in the German context
and then also in Minnesota.
And so that is when I just
really became curious about
just meaning of home and how
we can create more inclusive
spaces that are embracing of biodiversity,
but also cultural diversity
which is important
for climate change and just
on multiple different levels.
So just got more curious about that.
And then, yeah, I was retaining
my Danish dual citizenship
two years ago before coming
to (indistinct) environment.
And I met this woman
who's out in rural Denmark
and she had this lovely garden of seeds
that had previously been legal
in Denmark up until 2015.
And she told me this wonderful
story about seed saving
in Denmark and that's what led me here.
And yeah, I did all the
filming and editing on my own
and I just used a Sony A7
and had some lovely support
from the Yale program on
refugees and also from
other funders to help
me get there and do it.
- It's really impressive.
It's really, it's really cool, thank you.
Very nice documentary.
- Thanks.
- [Audience] I have a
technical question about
the seed bank, which I
know a little bit about.
I'm a backyard gardener and a seed saver.
I don't know how much
time you spent there.
So I understand the basic premise
of what that's meant to do.
But you know, like I
have seeds, it's funny,
I was just planting some
lettuce seeds spring started
that are maybe 10 years
old and none of them
were viable anymore.
So how does the seed bank,
I know it's very cold,
that's part of the
premise of why it's there,
but how do they deal with the fact that
like seeds do need to be grown,
it's my understanding and my experience?
Or they're not viable.
So are they not only a repository,
but that they constantly
have to grow them to re-seed the bank,
which seems daunting on the scale
of the billions of seeds there.
- Yeah, yeah.
There are quite a few seeds there.
And the question of germination
is really important.
And through like the countries
that deposit seeds there,
I know every couple of years
they'll have new deposits
that are made, but the gene
bank in Svalbard does not
do any of the germination themselves.
So people would have to
like send in new varieties
to replace the older ones.
But the Nordic Genetic Resource Center
does do germination tests.
And that is, yeah, so
like (indistinct) said
who is at the end of the film,
they do germination testing with like
all the Nordic countries and
they kind of control the,
make sure that all the
germination rates are good,
but for the rest of the
countries they are not, yeah,
they don't help with that, yeah.
- [Audience] Great film, great story.
- Thank you.
- Can I ask you something about
the seed bank in Svalbard.
- Yes.
- So day lend out seeds
and then people have to
reproduce them and send
back new ones, right?
- So the Svalbard gene bank is
almost like just like a bank.
So every country that
sends in their seeds,
they can keep them there,
but the Nordic Genetic Resource Center
which is based in Sweden, they
can send people some seeds
out and then they can grow them, yeah.
- Okay, so the Norwegian
ones are just sitting there.
- Yes.
- And not doing anything.
- And like Rob says, so, well yeah,
don't they run out of seeds eventually?
- Yeah, eventually, yeah.
- [Audience] What is the
idea that you just want
the genetic code in there
and it's not necessarily
you're saving the seed as a viable thing?
- Well, I mean sometimes
seeds are viable forever
because I know that in
archeology we sometimes find
viable seeds that are thousands of years.
- [Audience] Yeah.
- They're mainly weeds, but still, yeah.
- [Audience] As far as I know,
Svalbard it's a backup of the backup.
- Yeah.
- [Audience] So we have
institute cultivation,
we have gene banks for like,
this is a CGIAR seed bank
in Svalbard?
It's part of the CGIAR?
- It's a part of the Nordic
Genetic Resource Center
and crop trust, there's like two entities.
- [Audience] There's an
international organization
for reading varieties,
but also conservation.
And for instance, that
international organization
has a gene bank for
banana seeds and that one
is in (indistinct) in Belgium.
And bananas too are, yeah,
you cannot save banana seeds forever.
So you have to renew your
gene bank all the time.
And this one is all those
different seed banks.
You have some for weed, some
for rice, some for maize,
and I guess they do
lots of the conservation
also planting it out,
and every five years you have to renew it.
And then they, around the globe,
the seed banks will send it
to Svalbard so far away
from everywhere in the ice
as a backup of the backup.
So it's not, they don't have,
they mainly have the seeds
that stay well for
a long time.
- A long time.
- [Audience] And they
don't do the outgrowing
because the other seed banks that mostly-
- Okay.
- Do the outgrowing.
- Yeah, but they have seed
banks everywhere, don't they?
I mean, and I know that when
Aleppo got bombed 10 years ago,
they lost their seed bank.
- [Audience] Yeah, yeah.
- But then they borrowed
from, I don't know where.
- They borrowed from Svalbard, yeah.
- Yeah.
- They had like-
- That's the back-
- Yeah, the backup, right.
Exactly, and that was
the first and only time
that a withdrawal has
been made from Svalbard.
- Oh.
- But while I was there,
there was some people
from the new gene bank because, yeah,
the first one was destroyed
but then they made a new one
in Lebanon and they had a
representative that came
from that gene bank to come
deliver 12 new varieties
to the Svalbard global seed vault.
And he is a endurance
athlete and he was paralyzed
from the waist down.
And so he used this exoskeleton
to walk up the mountain
and it was like a hike for climate hope.
And it took 10 hours to walk
all the way up the mountain.
And we all did it together,
and then he got to deliver the new seeds.
So it just shows that they
have a good relationship.
But they're a part of
CGIAR actually, yeah.
- So they actually regrew
the seeds in theory,
devastated as it is,
because, I don't know,
I read somewhere, I'm not sure where,
that they had to regrow them in Lebanon
or in even in Morocco
because it was impossible.
I mean, you know, there are
landmines everywhere in Syria.
It's very hard to do agriculture, really.
- Yeah, they had taken them to Lebanon.
Yeah.
- Okay.
- Yeah.
- [Audience] I have a question.
So I understand that you
want to increase diversity
into the seeds that you
have, but isn't there as well
like a risk in bringing some
plants that are non-indigenous
that can sort of like
take over the local ones?
- Yeah, I definitely think
that that is an important risk.
And one of the reasons that
I think some more harsh seed
legislation came out in addition
to other reasons as well.
But I think that with like
careful research and testing
and making sure that things
won't be like super invasive
and that they'll be, yeah,
good hosts to the land as well.
I think that it's really
important and something that
we're gonna have to look
more into with climate change
as we have seed varieties,
a lot of monoculture
is less adaptive to climate change,
so finding things that are
more adaptive and responsive
is gonna be more of a need.
But yeah, it's definitely
important to make sure
it's not super invasive.
- The other thing is that all
this monoculture is, I mean,
there are patents on certain
seeds for various grains etc.
Owned by what?
Monsanto, somebody like that.
Now, how did they manage to
take a patent out on seeds?
- Yeah, I think-
- And all these laws,
you know, I mean, okay,
so they don't obey the laws
in Scandinavia, good for them,
but they do in lots of places and, yeah.
- Yeah, yeah, I think like how
harsh seed legislation is now
and like intellectual
property rights of seeds
is really important to look at.
I'm not super expert on
intellectual property rights
specifically, just owning of
intellectual property right
over a species or over a
living entity is kind of
a bizarre concept in general.
And especially with
companies like Monsanto,
which is now Bayer and just
kinda capitalizing and profiting
off of, yeah, nature, has
never turned out so well
in the past, so yeah.
- Yeah.
- [Audience] Yeah, gonna try
and weigh in a little bit here.
So these laws, originally,
I think the core mission
of these laws that
determine what kind of seeds
farmers can sow, is
national food security.
That's the bottom line.
You don't want farmers to sell whatever,
which would import plant diseases
or which would reduce yields,
which would then endanger
food security in Denmark,
context of the entire European Union
or for instance in the US.
And there's two ways of going about it.
In the US, the American model,
it's all, it's torts laws.
It's afterwards.
If you're a seed company
and you sell seeds
that turn out not to germinate,
then you can be sued in court
and the penalties will be
so high that you have
a very strong incentive
to be very careful about
the seeds you disseminate.
In Europe, we've somehow I
think a worse system, actually,
I think it's originally
coming from France,
although I'm not sure.
We're gonna do it beforehand.
If you want to hand out seeds,
or if you want as a company,
you want to distribute seeds,
you need to ask permission
for the specific variety, you
need to register your variety.
That's the US conditions.
And those are the same conditions
for intellectual property
and for market access.
But here, for market access conditions,
then your variety is registered,
a new variety of weeds
and that per batch of seeds
that you want to sell,
you also need to go through
a government procedure
where they will check
on the batch of seeds.
Now what's happened here
and I think that that may be
another problem of interpretation
in the movie that I see
is at some point you
say Denmark has the most
liberal seed laws.
That's I think not true.
That could be the pendulum
coming back because Denmark
and the Netherlands are easily
the two countries in Europe,
I think with the most
intensive agriculture.
- Yeah.
- The Netherlands is the number one,
it's the number one exporter,
Denmark has all its dairy.
And they have government and agri industry
is so much involved that
you have a huge degree
of implementation of these laws.
If you go to Greece or to
Italy, you have more land races,
agriculturists, more small scale.
It's also like Mediterranean
cuisine, all these things.
- Yeah.
- And what has happened,
it's 10 years ago in Europe,
NGOs have actually scored
something of a victory
and have been able to put on the agenda
of European parliament
that all those seed laws,
let's say beforehand
when you can cultivate,
are too strict and that there has to be
a conservation corrective.
- Yeah.
- Eventually the entire
conservation directive
was on the agenda, but it's
NGOs again that torpedoed it
because it wasn't radical
enough, it didn't allow for
enough conservation.
I guess some kind of compromise
but I don't know the details
could have been that a
country like Denmark said,
hey, we've gone a lot
further than many of these
other countries, let's now
try and allow some more
conversation our own
country, for instance,
by not applying European laws as strictly.
And so I think if you say
Denmark has the most liberal laws
for conservation and for seed exchange,
I interpret that as Denmark
having gone back from
precipice of being the most
agro industrial country
together with the Netherlands.
So sorry for the (indistinct).
- No, it's fine.
- No, but I mean this,
this farmer who was
farming a field for rye
and he was saying, okay,
so we use different seeds
and use different kinds of rye
and it makes different kind of flour,
but I guess he doesn't
distribute the seeds.
So in that sense, you know,
it's within the EU or whatever
rules they are about.
You can't sell the seeds but
there's nothing to prevent you
from actually planting them again.
- [Audience] Sure, small scale
in your own farm and stuff,
mostly it's that (indistinct).
- I also say for the
comment on the most liberal
seed legislation, that wasn't
something I personally said.
It was something that somebody
from the Danish seed saving,
yeah, Danish seed savers said as well.
And I think that these
regulations on seed diversity
do come from national security.
That's something that I've
witnessed in my own research
and looking at this from
more of an environmental,
anthropological lens is that
a lot of the seed legislation
popped up around the same
time that there was a lot
of conversation around eugenics
and that there was this idea
of genetic purity that has emerged.
And if you look at old seed
catalogs, you'll see something
that they will advertise for
with using the same language
that a lot of people within
the Nazi regime used as well.
And so I think that while
there is like a biological lens
looking at how we regulate seeds,
there is also a social
lens that got mixed up
within this as well which
has been destructive
for the genetic diversity
of our food systems, yeah.
- But so yeah, I don't think
they're so liberal in Denmark
they're just going to, you know, say,
well there's this rule and we don't care.
This is a normal Danish
attitude, you know, so.
- [Audience] Yeah, true, true.
They're not the most faithful clients
of European participation.
They say sometimes, say
Brussels, there's other countries
that are more loyal to
Brussels than Denmark, so.
- Right.
That's the same.
But no, but I mean, if
Monsanto owns the patent
on all these agricultural
seeds, well good for them.
But I mean, they also
own the patent on all
the horrible artificial, you
know, fertilizers, etc., etc.
Roundup I think is made by them also.
So it seems like, you know,
they have it all sort of
sewn up, you know?
You have to have our seeds and
you have to use our poisons
to make these seeds grow
and it becomes, you know,
maybe a monopoly, which
I do think would be good
if somebody could break
it up a little bit.
But I don't know how extensive
it is and where it exists
all the time and for everybody.
- Yeah, I feel like in the US context
and probably also for the Danish context,
that most agriculture is, yeah,
using these kinds of seeds.
And I think that the more
radical versions of having seeds
that are heritage varieties
is still a very small scale.
But I think a lot of younger
farmers that I had spoken to
in Denmark, they were
looking at this and saying,
this is not a good system.
This is not a system that's
gonna be around forever
because it's destroying our
climate and it's not going
to survive through certain disasters
or it's not going to be
very hospitable anywhere.
So they have a bit of an
interest to disturb it as well.
So I thought that that gave
me a lot of hope that there is
a lot of young farmers
that are doing things
a little bit differently.
- Well, I guess also by now
there are a lot of people
who are interested in organic farming,
which there certainly was not before.
But I don't know, I mean, I
don't know in this country
how big it is, it's getting
bigger all the time I guess.
But it could take many
years before, you know,
people give up on all these
various chemicals that they use.
So.
- [Audience] Can you talk
a little bit more about
like you mentioned like
the adaptation as well,
that probably needs to happen
even if you like it or not,
with the climate change?
- Yeah, and does adaptation
and climate change broadly or,
yeah.
- [Audience] No, for the seeds, obviously.
So I don't know, what path do you see,
and also I guess as in other issues
regarding the lower income countries
with respect to the developed ones?
- Yeah.
Yeah, I think that this is like
a really amazing opportunity
for in situ and ex situ
seeds banks to work together
in developing these seeds.
And this is something that
I witnessed when I went
to the Nordic Genetic
Resource Center in Sweden.
They had this very popular
oat milk company called Oatly,
and they were working with
them and had a whole field
of different oat varieties.
And for researching what
oat varieties are the most
drought resistant or the
most heat tolerant or, yeah,
what produced the most oat seeds.
And so that there is some research there
which I think is helpful.
And these bigger gene banks,
I think that they have
a lot more resources
so they have an obligation
to help with companies
and help with individuals to understand
better adaptation practices.
And I think that this can
be a way also for maybe also
lower income countries to work
with genetic resource centers
to understand how to grow seeds,
but also to rely on the
local networks as well.
Because I think a lot of the
local networks have knowledge
that these ex situ seed
banks do not because yeah,
you have a situation
where you have Svalbard
that doesn't have any of
the like cultural knowledge
attached to the seed as well.
It's not like you have, like
when you scan the barcode
of the seed that's kept up
there, that a recipe pops up
or the history of growth pops
up either, it's just a seed.
So if yeah, everybody lost
their knowledge one day,
then there'd be nothing
to keep that alive either,
which is why cultural
knowledge is important
for adaptation as well.
- Yeah, well one of your speakers in here,
I forget which one, the
Norwegian one maybe,
was saying that, yeah,
it's important to save
all these seeds but we also
have to save the knowledge
of where to grow them and how to grow them
and where not to do it, etc.
And yeah, so all these
millions of seeds in Svalbard,
do they come with instructions?
- No, no.
- [Audience] Nobody's doing that?
- But it says where they came from, right?
- Yeah.
- It does say that.
- It says where they came from, yeah.
- Okay, yeah.
- [Audience] Charly, this could
actually be, if you wanted,
this could be a live work
if you were, because I mean,
you're saying it yourself,
this is not something that
you can document in a way of,
we're gonna have a
database, we're gonna put,
I don't know, zeros and ones in it,
or this is something you
can only document that
for posterity via video actually.
- Yeah.
- And via witnesses and recipes.
And, yeah, perhaps there
are people who they should,
people should pay for this.
And perhaps you're in a
position to convince somebody
to pay you to do this.
- Yeah, maybe.
- Go around the countryside
and and I dunno,
in somewhere where there's
lots of heirloom varieties
and start from there.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Audience] I mean, in
some way it's a lot of work,
but it's not terribly
challenging concept, right?
You just-
- No.
- It's a lot of groundwork.
- But how do you do this?
- You interview people, you get
some recipes, you have some,
you know, some basic
rubric of how many people
you would talk to for each one.
And it's a lot of groundwork
but I think that it's a great idea.
And you could somewhat
codify for each seed
you want to have this
many representatives.
- Yeah.
- [Audience] And for a country,
for instance, take example,
again, the example of Italy,
you don't have to do this for Italy.
There's still a lot of heirloom varieties
compared to other rich countries.
But the Italian kitchen is so
well known around the world
that all these, but if you, I don't know,
I'm thinking of a country
like Mali, for instance.
- Yeah.
- [Audience] Just a random
example of an African country.
If you would go around there,
then there's a lot to say
and probably also a lot
of culinary knowledge
and to share later with
other people and to motivate
the global public to
be interested in these.
- Yeah.
- Land raised, heirloom
varieties in the Malian kitchen.
- Yeah, that's so true.
Yeah, I feel like that's
a really good idea.
And I think that there's been
a lot of really amazing work
with like visual anthropology
and visual storytelling
within indigenous communities
in the US and Canada
in documenting traditional
practices as people are becoming
older and trying to figure
out how to pass knowledge down
to younger populations.
But yeah, even reaching the global-
- Well, maybe nobody's
asking any questions either.
- Yeah.
- That's another problem.
- Yeah, but then you also
have the risk of like,
if you do go to, yeah,
countries like that are maybe
lower income or go to
countries that are really
genetically rich, like Mali or something,
and you publish or you have all this like,
knowledge that's kept up,
then you really wanna be sure
that it doesn't get in
the wrong hands as well
because there's definitely
seed companies that'd be
interested in having
that kind of knowledge.
- [Audience] True.
- Yeah.
- [Audience] Yeah, there's also a question
of cultural appropriation.
- Yeah.
- [Audience] What very
often happens in the,
so I work actually in Africa,
I know more about Africa than Europe,
and it's actually seed
companies are not interested
in this knowledge.
They're not interested
in, most seed companies
are not interested in most of
the crops that are grown by,
traditional crops grown
by smallholder farmers
in the South.
And what many farmers will do
is they will, for instance,
they will have a food crop which can be
an international traded crop
also or a crop that you find
in many, many countries like
rice, like wheat or even,
sorry, or whatever.
And then they will have, for
instance, a cash crop like,
like (indistinct), but
they will also on the side
have some of their more
traditional veggies or other crops.
So they have a diverse farming exercise.
And seed companies are
not interested in say,
the site's operation
of heirloom varieties.
This is something that's
really on farmer's time,
on farmer's books.
Seed companies they're, maximally,
they're trying to replace
this but there's no market
in it, it's too small,
it's too regionally diverse.
They are interested in the
other two, the cash crop
and the main crops for food.
And what you see there is
very often that those crops
are not local to the area.
Very often they've come
through colonialism,
they've been introduced in other area.
For instance, potato is a new world crop
but you also find it in many
different places in Africa.
Rice for instance in west
Africa is not indigenous,
or at least not the type
of rice you find now.
But at the same time, what
happens is that the farmers
who are not growing their traditional crop
that they have always been growing,
what the entire richness
of genetic diversity,
they are growing all varieties
of the 1950s, 1960s, 1970s,
that still have been
introduced by the colonizer.
And the problem is then
that many seed companies
are actually not
interested in these markets
because they're too small
and farmers are too poor.
So instead of growing the
newest commercial varieties
of rice, farmers are growing
very old commercial varieties
of rice that also need fertilizer,
that are also genetically poor quality.
But that on top of all
that don't yield enough.
So in many African
countries, in my experience,
I would say that there's
that seed companies,
that we need more seed
companies coming in to focus
on certain of their cultures.
But your story is more around local crops,
the veggies and yeah.
But for many farmers, their
main cultivation is not in that.
- Yeah.
- No, no, you have to be rich
to do all this experimenting.
I mean, you know, you couldn't
do it on a commercial scale
if you didn't know what was it going to be
and how was it gonna turn out.
You could not.
- Sure.
- Yeah.
- But then it's like,
maybe it's okay if things
are on a smaller scale in the future.
Like maybe it's not super
sustainable to have huge,
huge plots of land that are
just owned by a couple people.
And, yeah, maybe that
is a little optimistic
because I feel like
especially with Bill Gates'
recent decisions to buy
up all the farmland.
But I think it's gonna have
to be more localized maybe
in the future.
Yeah.
- [Audience] But the
thing is that, I mean,
there the question is how to balance
this competing objective.
Because in any case you
cannot, and they could not do,
I mean, some small
farmers, they also need to,
I mean, sustain themselves.
So it's not that they might
want to grow different variety
of plant, but at some point
you also need to be able
to be like (indistinct)-
- Survive off of that.
- To survive.
- Absolutely, yeah.
- Well, I mean, this I guess
is the industrialization
of, you know, agriculture,
and yeah, we have that.
But you know, there should
be room for experimenting
and I think it's good your
age is exactly the age
you should do this.
- One of the the cool things-
- I'm telling you.
- I think with the farmer
that he's like standing
in the middle of the wheat
fields, that I think-
- Rye.
- Rye, yeah, rye fields,
is that like he has this
beautiful farm plot that's got,
yeah, 12 different varieties
of all these different things
growing together, which is really cool.
And as you're driving up to
the farm, there are all these
farms around him that every
plant is the same size,
there's no birds around, it's very quiet.
And then you get up to his
farm and there's explosions
of birds happening everywhere,
it's super diverse.
He's not using like
fertilizers on his land.
And yeah, it was very
much a different feeling.
So I think it was cool to see
like what it could be like
as well, yeah.
- Thank you, more questions?
- [Audience] No, that was lovely.
It was great, great talk.
- Thank you.
- So thank you for being here
and showing us your documentary.
We want to see your next show.
- Yes, definitely.
(audience claps)